how's it going brahs but I just I find
myself that's pretty pathetic I'm back
you didn't notice oh well either way I'm
back so let's celebrate I wish you I've
been shooting a secret project
in LA I had a blast and then now I'm
back and I can make videos at home why
are you telling me this because for
maybe eight months I prepared for going
away to this thing and I did a lot of
videos in advance and I think the
majority of what I shot will never see
the light of day I think it was really
really hard for nothing so that's that's
a plus but something I realized when I
came back is that I don't want to do
that anymore
I don't want to work ahead I don't want
to keep making videos just because I
need to work ahead technically I'm going
away in a few days as well and I'm
supposed to do that right now like I'm
supposed to work ahead so that when I go
away there will still be videos but I'm
just burned out I'm too tired of doing
that and that I'm here and I'm just like
I just want to make videos that I want
to make and that I think you bros will
enjoy watching and that's what I'm gonna
do I just thought I'd let you know
another thing I want to talk about is
that for some reason all the projects
that I've been working on is happening
at once I did the shoot in LA which was
amazing I had such a blast
I had like the best time ever I can't
wait for you to watch it it's gonna be
so awesome and then the game came out
and you bros really really supported it
and that was
because I didn't know if it would do
well or not and if the game doesn't do
well then we lost a bunch of money and I
don't know it so I'm really glad you
brought supported it and I'm really glad
you're enjoying it it really really
means a lot I got to go in the Colbert
show recently which was so scary but I
think I did okay and the book is coming
out next month there's just so much
stuff going on and I'm just so happy how
things are turning out I feel I feel so
fortunate to be doing all these things
and I just also want to be clear that
I'm not doing all these different things
to try and get out of youtube I'm not
doing them to try and I'm happy here
YouTube I'm happy to do what I'm doing I
started making videos because I love
making gaming gaming videos and I keep
making it because that's what I love to
do like a lot of youtubers they use the
YouTube as kind of like a leaping
platform to get somewhere else which is
totally fine that's just not my
intention I'm just doing all these other
things because they're fun and they're
fun opportunities and I think they're
fun for us as well so just want to be
clear on that but yeah now that I'm back
I have more time to actually make the
kind of videos that takes that extra
effort like the Fridays with PewDiePie
or like pips there's everything YouTube
high school almost are the videos that I
really really really love and I think
are reasons why I maybe you discover
this channel I actually have more time
to do those kind of videos and I feel
like they've been neglected for a while
like probably while I've been trying to
prepare for this month that has been so
that I'm back I'm excited to do that and
I think you bros should just be excited
for better videos not to say that
they've been bad right I just think it's
so cool I almost been doing YouTube for
five years most channels that became
like really big really fast died out
really fast as well and I
really worried when my channel is going
that the same thing would happen to me
and it's been five years now you bros
are still here and i just really really
appreciate you sticking around because i
want to keep making videos because i
still love doing it and it'd be cool if
you would watch them alright that's all
for me for now
I'll see you bros in future videos stick
off some rest